nella musica video e sono vari genio ci
siamo studiati e sfracassato i trequarti
di minerva nel da settimane durante la
settimana perché io registrasse geometri
dash l'espansione che sarebbe già metri
dai mezzi e niente ragazzi l'ho appena
scaricata ci sono tipo dei livelli nuovi
ho provato uno a caso giusto prevedere
stesse funzionava e niente ragazzi
quindi facciamo questi non so che cosa
ci sia di diverso credo sia uguale anzi
spero faccia incazzare un po meno bello
cos'era quella roba
oddio che frigo no vabbè cos'è sta roba
ma serio non sono un idiota roma ma che
fino a parte la musica che spacca ma non
è tanto quello il livello è veramente
figo cioè ragazzi sembra un remix di
jack sparrow in pirati dei caraibi o dio
è vabbè si muovono le cose le scale ma
anche nel reporter cribbio fermi che ne
applicate lega pro è un bordello ma è
una figata dai starmi san rocco seno
vincere adesso senza neanche morire una
volta dunque basta ho deciso
giuro non sto scherzando
[Musica]
cosa sto facendo più addio
tanta roba o da ragazzi non saprò mai
più ve lo dico
e giù famila mi chiamo e bellissimo
regalo ce la sto facendo e non vorrei
dire non sono morto ancora una volta da
quando ho detto la roba di madonna no
porca put l'adrano sono the pc e vabbè
captati viene solo lega sono morta ha 80
quante quanto ero quant'ero 53 ora sto
livello beh ce la faccio legata ormai ho
capito adesso adesso mi pendice ogni
volta che mi si compia di comprare
qualcosa davanti nicchio malissimo ma
malissimo proprio è veramente
impossibile
ed è solo il primo è ragazzi non so
immaginare gli altri se nel caso sono
gli altri se su wikipedia cerchio
youtuber incredibilmente intelligente
c'è la mia faccia a non c'è e anche
fragile l'ipad per carità di dio non lo
potevamo fare un po più resistente così
lo lanciava dalla finestra e vabbè ma
siamo tipo solo a metà ragazzi manca
manca un chilometro ancora non ce la
farò mai dove si dovrà esistere un ora e
mezza bravo bravo bravo chi cazzo era
quello oggi è prodotto
è quanto ce ne maledizione quanto google
a sto cazzo di livello dai 6 anni per
finire un livello record 6 ma pessimo
con le cose fantastico
[Musica]
non so neanche come ho fatto non importa
non fatemi domande va bene così ai
ragazzi il primo è andato perfetto
mancano gli altri due che spero di
riuscire a fare perché se non ha mica è
impossibile ci proviamo dai bee team
biking arena ci sarà una canzone
vichinga
alla madonna che cazzo l'aviatore no
peggio che la casa e queste ragazze la
caverna
oggi a hama a una mappa ma poi è bravo
ragazzo bravo bravo bravo giovanna fra
[Musica]
che figata ragazzi sta livello più che
da giocare bellissimo da vedere non so
perché mica la finisco io mi sono preso
bene ragazzi lo finisco
arriva al drop ma certe
[Musica]
sta venendo un livello decente per una
volta nella vita ho dovuto rovinare
tutto per fare il dj sono un
jenny wolf
dai dai dai dai dai dai dai dai taxi
meno male che ci sono indicazioni perché
sono ancora sarei morto 26 mila volte
bravissimo minchia coop in faccia lo
presi in faccia ti ho chiesto il
permesso cubo attivati su dieci kart in
faccia maledizione porca
l'aidaa 86 quasi ci siamo siamo madonna
che bordello che bordello che bordello
chi cazzo sono quelli via
vade retro gesù aiuto ce so
se cioè sono morto dentro fa i jazz che
come tutti i ragazzi di 20 anni passa le
giornate a rimorchiare le tipe perché
questo che i ragazzi di 20 anni fanno o
forse ma dai ragazzi son riuscito a fare
il secondo va bene anche così hermon
robles almeno così finiamo tutti i
livelli non solo episodio però spero che
non sono sul sicuro da adesso questo è
il primo tentativo da adesso un solo
tentativo e vinco questo qua in questo
tentativo finco tutto subito al primo
tentativo
sono convinto però suo carico
scommettiamo
scommettiamo non so il disco metto fiat
mario per cosa scommettete se avete
voglia di scommettere lo strumento che
mario porca eva
ecco penso che tu mario va bene così
comunque ragazzi ancora ma vaffan cuore
c'è una chiave ho visto una chiave che
hanno scosso e serviva non lo so ok ok
ok
così grande ok ho battuto il record
ragazzi parte troppo
tenetevi pronti per troppa cielo quasi
un cerchio tra sono perché non
lo so usare io sto coso che va su e giù
ho preso la chiave
oddio ho preso una chiave per sbaglio
non capito come oddio è ok
serviva a prenderla manente la chiave ho
capito ok ok ma che parte troppo quando
parte i prossimi caso quindi dico
[Musica]
bye bye bye bye bye si no no non avevo
capito come fare ma l'inizio ero lì ce
l'avevo vabbè ma la moneta me l'ha
lasciata giusto cioè non è che me la
toglie una gara tolta sto stronzo dai mi
togli la male ma che cazzo vi mettono
gli achievement in alto che non vedo
bene
no
sì sì dài dài le leve che la supposta
vai con la supposta vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai sul posto dai vice ceo di chi
prego vinci ti prego vai da conto dura
in quanto 2 a sto cazzo di livello
quanto dura madonna come mi sono salvato
come mi son salvarla non è possibile
devo vincere la pasta se mi sono salvato
così perché devo vincerla
[Musica]
cos'è ma che cazzo
sì sì sì mi chiacchierò alla fine a un
certo punto poi non ho detto niente
perché se parlo mi concentro non mi
ricordo verso il 90 per cento quando sul
teschio ho pensato tra me e me è una
roba del tipo se non la vinco adesso la
vinco più se non la faccio neanche più
non ci prova neanche più impossibile
doveva andarmi bene stavolta perché non
l'avrei mai più fatto impossibile
ragazzi miei ho finito geometri da
schmelzer e sapete che cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che da oggi in avanti la
passerà a fiumi della serie dei pepi ho
finito geometri da sci d'accordo
ragazzuoli concluso che l'episodio è
stato ciò avuto veramente una botta di
culo alla fine perché non avrei mai più
fatto nella mia vita spero che ai video
vi sia piaciuto spero che facciano altri
livelli perché è figo c'è scritto coming
soon quindi faranno uscire sicuramente
qualcosa quindi ragazzuoli spero che
video vi sia piaciuto cosa sei tu se vi
è piaciuto al momento è un mi piace
anche a prese di facebook un video
tratto nella descrizione source and the
city sky ci vediamo il proprio video
bello ragazzi